[Applaudissements]
elle si en plus vous le dire il est
19h56 on est très en retard vous je vous
dis à deux minutes près vous étiez
chocolat sous pression plaît allez
revenez sur isère il n'y a pas de cause
il n'y aura rien ce soir au musée getty
des revenus protégés sur un galet je
vais vous dire quelque chose s'est
vraiment je le prends très mal
[Applaudissements]
le téléspectateur votre manque de
confiance je le prend très mal et
surtout d'amis benhaim kelly beethoven
qui jetteront ami maxime galy reste
molle et mal mais nous on le prend tout
court
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
ma salive ou deux secondes 30 secondes
installez-vous de seconde va bien et
christine revenez aller ça suffit soit
solidaire isabelle pour vous remercier
ce week-end on ira prendre un chocolat
en moyenne ce quelque chose c'est que
les boosts plus et ronan les allers
retours
doc gynéco le temps qu'ils sont deux
tabourets ya cinq minutes à l'émission
est en direct émission de foot ce soit
et cédric vous avez vos lauriers on
feignait c'est une émission normal donc
on y va le gosse et de teneur durera le
débrief sur la sur la séquence
voilà partis chaussures nous la salle
éprouvé toute la semaine que vous étiez
un petit chenapan la preuve est que
chocolat les chroniqueurs ont du mal à
se remettre du chocolat gates évidemment
donc je vous remets le laurier
l'animateur qui restera toujours un
grand enfant
quand même les enfants mais vous avez
servir les autres mais aussi des
salaires et quand vous êtes généreux
vous partez avec des invités et le
public comme un enfant vous avez triché
si un compétiteur donc voulait
absolument être le meilleur à tous les
sports que moi ne mettre pas et vous
vous en foutez complètement qui est une
émission à faire là les gars c'est le
dernier
celle dernière c'est le dernier et le
dernier le dernier le vernis série
d'aidés bartender 16 personnes
auditionnées
alors pour finir comment la foi de
clénay mbappé qui va être sacrés
champions de france s'est terminée le
paris saint germain s'impose 3 à 1
avec la sobriété de la joie de cyril
hanouna qui réussit à glisser un verre
sur une maison en bois
[Applaudissements]
c'est l'accomplissement de toute une vie
incroyable ajoie c'est magnifique alors
chaque semaine on fait le point sur
l'état de la jeunesse actuelle est au
niveau de la langue française je peux
vous dire que on n'est toujours pas sur
une pente ascendante henry c'est le
loiret des phrases les plus
hallucinantes de télé réalité c'est dans
la chine du japon et qui fait travail
comme ça il vous passez me 82 voilà
qu'il à des années lumières je ne sais
pas de quoi tu es trop fort alors il a
dérobé
j'avoue que quand ils escaladent disent
[Musique]
que je n'arrive pas c'est plus fort que
moi j'ai le vertige bercy calais pas
horizons alors cette semaine j'ai
beaucoup regardé les jeux diffusés sur
france télévisions juste parce que ça
m'éclate de voir la tête des candidats
qui après 12 victoires apprennent qu'ils
repartent avec une machine à faire de la
limonade
c'est un peu compliqué et sinon c'est
joe n'y a pas de pognon ya de grands
moments de tristesse c'est le laurier
des moments de solitude dans les jeux
télé on sait que dans motus il ya plus
de moments de solitude que de boulari
muet gélinotte ge est haute et elodie
mais bon aussi j'ai les notes
bon temps des chiffres des lettres un
candidat s'est un peu lâché et ariel et
la kiffer d'habitants encore une fois
que six lettres que s'il est décoté
willaume qu'on dise est oui avec second
oui un autre
kaunas à l'est et donc trouver l'intrus
on a surtout trouvé le meilleur
imitateur d'animaux du monde
mehdi et mythes très bien des animaux si
je demande le perroquet par exemple
besoin d'un perchoir
c'est pour jouer perchoir merci
tous les après midi sur france 2 il ya à
faire conclut une émission qu'on peut
pas regarder si on a moins de 93 ans ces
prêts j'adore je suis d'avant il a ayant
ou vous ayez une caméra cachée tout à
l'heure ils ont été formidables savoir
tonneins à carreaux guette tous les
jours c'est choisir c'est sophie davant
qui présente et ça cartonne le principe
c'est de venir vendre un objet que t'a
piqué d'un salon de thé grand mère à des
experts acheteurs et la star des
acheteurs c'est bien sûr pierre jascha
lançons à horizon sur l'enfant qui a la
particularité d'être mon opposé
capillaires et à chaque fois que je
regarde l'émission je le vois plus chine
et des mecs que des objets je lui remets
donc le laurier du gars qui devrait
s'appeler pierre-jean show lens on sait
bien
[Musique]
bonjour je n'aime perdre mon temps et
toute souriante
bonjour killian kiely à nador surtout
viennent vous mais nous de vite sur
scène aussi
par isidore qu'il y avait des 41 un
petit meuble en bus ça du temps les
meubles à 9
alors imaginez maintenant j'adore tout
ce qui me charme ans il est temps de
terminer le moment que j'attendais
impatiemment chaque jeudi l'élection du
tarn abbas rappelle le principe de temps
là bas c'est celui ou celle qui a le
plus tacler ses collègues il ya toujours
en suspens
incroyable pour savoir si la porte c'est
le cinquième lors et 5e alors pour un
sens j'ai gagné quatre fois quatre fois
sur cinq alors je pense qu'avec tout ce
qui vous a fait cette semaine il est
normal que pour la cinquième fois
consécutive le loriot thomas bach
reviennent à cyril hanouna
grâce à toi il ya beaucoup bien qu'il se
fait du mien mais par rapport à la mer
si apparemment elle comprend bien doc
gynéco à écouter merci kelly on a trouvé
votre fonction dans l'émission m6
rediffusait une barque a intitulé zumba
métal abonnés génial - regardez vous
avez regardé ça vous oui j'ai adoré leur
ca c'était vers 23h20 temps à leur sens
à la 3e reprise les regarder pourquoi on
n'a pas mis j'étais à la bibliothèque
j'étais accompagné d'un étudiant et puis
ça pête un temps fou avant le chirurgien
lui c'est un témoin si jimmy c'est quoi
le rapport tintin jamie puisqu'ils sont
pas parfois lui et tu sais plus j'ai le
il a des relents d'nrj 12
[Rires]
[Musique]
et m
[Applaudissements]